Một công chức mới dòng ngay giới hệ số 1 phải 3 sau chỉ đặt khoảng 4 phải bấy kìu đồng 1 tháng, trước khi chừng báo hiểm, trong khi chỉ phí sinh qua tối thiếu tại đối thầy phổ biến từ sau đến bấy kìu đồng 1 tháng,
điều này có thấy một khoảng cách đáng kể giữa thu nhập dạ như cầu sống kế bản, hệ quá là người lo đồng khó sống đặc lập bằng lưu,
phải khu thuộc dòng 1 thu nhập 4 xuống, giám đồng lực dạ chất lường 1 xong,
giò đó có thể khảnh đình 1 tháng phải 5 diệu đồng chỉ đặt 1 tiêu ổng đình chưa đặt 1 tiêu báo đầm đời xong.
Mặt khác, từ ngày 1 tháng 1 tháng ngàn không chăm hềm xong, lương tốt thử dụng của khu dự nhiệm đã lên 5 tháng 1, 1 diệu đồng 1,
búng phải bấy kìu đồng 2, búng phải 1 diệu đồng 3, búng phải bấy kìu đồng 1, búng dùng là khoảng 4, búng phải búng bấy kìu đồng 1 tháng,
nếu lấy mức liên kênh xả mới 2,5 diệu, nhận dễ hệ số khởi điểm thấp thường gặp 1 phải 3 xong,
dịn lương theo công thức cử, kỹ khoảng 4 phải bấy kìu đồng 1 tháng, giới hệ số 2 phải 1 thì khoảng 5 phải bây giờ 1 tháng,
nó các khác người ảnh yếu thấp nhất chỉ dừa dịn hình mức liên tốt thử dụng bình quân,
còn người ảnh yếu 2 phải 1 thì chỉ dừa chấm, người chấm nướng dụng 1, giới mặt bằng chi phí đô thì nó chỉ là mức cầm cử chưa phải mức bảo đam cuộc sống ổn định.
Bấm lại, giịn lương các xả lên 2 phải nâm 3 chỗ đồng là cầm thiết chiêu chứ đủ để giải quyết cầm bản vài tỏng đợi sống người làm dịch trong khu dự công.
Trong điều kiện hính nè, mức 2 phải xong đồng đến 2 phải bài chỗ đồng hán, là phương át tôi ủy dệ tổng thệ, giữa đồng bảo tính khá tiên, giữa tạo được bướng kẻ thình thức kết,
đồng thầy mở đường cho các bướng kẻ khách xong, trong thời gian tới.